but I always knew at 16 when I left
school I wanted to be self-employed I'd
done loads of different side hustles I
used to go fishing used to catch fish at
Dover catch a train the first thing in
the morning for free come back and
pretend I lost my ticket so very cost
effective used to catch lots of mackerel
we used to take them around the house
and estate selling them which worked
very very well as a youngster I used to
buy and sell cars as well so I was
flipping cars that's while I was a
carpenter and Joiner so I used to do a
car a week I'd always buy a car that I
like so if I couldn't sell it it didn't
matter that would be my car but they
were always escort Mark twos that's the
car of choice and they always sold and I
was buying them for about 300 pounds
selling them between 500 and 600 so you
double your money and that's all it took
during the week and then someone would
come along we'd park it on a nice estate
as well when they came to visit it so
they'd give it a little bit of Kudos and
always did very well